fun
[Musique]
et
m
oh
[Musique]
tout le monde connaît la butte
montmartre
chaque année des millions de touristes
français ou étrangers viennent pour la
visiter
les escaliers de la butte qui n'en a pas
grimper les marches une à une
le sacré coeur tout en haut et puis la
place du tertre il est peintre
le spectacle est dans la rue laplace
mahdia titiste un anti cafard terrible
mais cette place là voilà tel que vous
ne l'avez jamais vu
[Musique]
et cette imaginez un petit matin d'été
m
bonjour 80 quoi alors si tu penses là
tout est noir il ya juste de réverbères
hatip en catimini car il fallait la main
il vient de monter tous les escaliers de
la butte de la rive la loin des x men en
rester-là ya pas de métro vers 10h10
pointe il reste de la place
tant mieux qu'ils en restent pas il ya
un problème ils cherchent ils tournent
en rond c'est que je vais mettre
aujourd'hui où ça pourrait marcher
on sait pas prenons le cas où il ya de
la place à y poser des pistons le pays
depuis ces trois bouts de bois qui les
met en place
et puis et alors là ça y est mort il est
là celui qui arrive le dernier
il est il s'est levé à 4h30 pendant une
petite demi-heure il arrive il est
marron et s'il a plus de fric ni rien du
tout il est bien obligé d'avoir une
place alors il vit à un gant qui y est
pas qui est qui et par là tu comprends
hiver le cheval est d'invoquer par la
ligue 1 revient ça fait des salades sont
possibles s'engueuler stable de sûr
c'est dur la place très dur régime très
dur parce que y'a pas en fait il ya
peut-être 150 g
mais 150 grammes qui sont bien décidés
quand même apporter ses montées sur les
pingouins qui comprend 30 ils sont tous
concurrents pas en fait
[Musique]
sous
ce
c'est tout
les premiers troquet ou très tard parce
qu'ils vont loin dans la nuit voilà
alors c'est pas pratique parce que quand
tu arrives à personne ils sont tous
fermés
il faut attendre qu'ils ouvrent pour
déjeuner
alors tu vois des spectres emmitouflés
dans des couvertures des voix qui
grelotte en attendant clubiste pauvres à
9h à le premier cube dans le coin il
ouvre à 9 heures tout le monde dans le
troquet alors c'est alors là c'est la
débandade
le garçon il fait tuer ou de la pâte à
café un cra et maman
tout le monde sait que c'est la folie
des chaufferettes à côté du radiateur
la première toile vendue quelque chose
vraiment le premier jour où je viens
avec un sujet à moi et tout ça marche ça
c'est merveilleux de cet épisode quoi
tout le monde tu as vu vendredi un barbu
hirsute qui vient de voir un mec énorme
là tu sais avec une moumoute avec des
poils partout
conjuguant habitués à passer l'hiver là
tu vois un dur à cuire qui vient de voir
a répliqué de 10 ça va ça marche bien
pour toi
pas mal alors tu perçois un peu d'ironie
peut-être un peu de jalousie c'est
possible mais un petit peu dans vie ici
c'est normal parce que lui l'a peut-être
pas vendu puis il ya la petite remarque
car nice yeuse en douce mais tu sais que
ta pour le droit pourquoi lg par loin
ben nous on n'a pas le droit parce que
parce que tu as droit qu'à deux toiles
c'est comme ça deux doivent pas 3 le
c'est pas marrant alors en temps dans
les urnes peu à peu tu sais pas ça mais
qu'est ce qui peut m'arriver si je
laisse trois toiles ah ben c'est simple
ils vont venir il est bon de présenter
leur cas et puis ils vont te dire suivez
nous
10h02 poste puis une amende et puis un
record maison j'étais emballé une fois
pas deux
oui
[Musique]
le vrai
il n'y a pas assez de place qu'il ya des
accords avec les bistrots ouvert à
monsieur est ce que vous voudriez bien
je me mettre dans votre terre à smara
oui pourquoi pas
on a l'habitude prendra de trois
consommations par jour puis tout ira
bien
oui mais je peux pas les payer massa
ferrari en donne moi un tableau enfin
un petit à ce niveau là il ya quand même
des arrangements possibles qui fait
qu'on arrive normalement à caser tout le
monde mais cette paix ni m
[Musique]
la période chaude pisse dans ma tête il
était vraiment la même chose
[Musique]
l'oin est la même et là je vais me fait
vraiment à ce qu'ils aient tout ça c'est
ça cette paralysie est ce que c'est
parce que la scène maladie non ce qui
gêne quand j'ai fait ou non un
déploiement la cls prochain un passage
de probité
merci à l'origine et marc ferret
dommage je n'étais live commerce et
moins jeunes pour lesquels 20 seront
distraction nous allons recommencer si
tu corresponds si ce que tu fais
sincèrement correspond à ce qu'on me
demande ça va ça marche bien tout il ya
tout est parfait mais si ça correspond
pas tout à fait obligés de modifier
effet obligé tu modifies inconsciemment
d'entre eux puis tu arrives à des
surprises voilà c'est à dire que tu
répètes il ya des groupes qui répètent
toujours le sujet depuis dix ans c'est
la première paye enfin concert avec sa
couleur fait la première des phares en
couleurs mais émotif c'est peut-être les
ces différentes couleurs différentes
compositions un peu changé j'ai retrouvé
un rappel aventure quand même même si
les motifs et la commerciale les faire
un tableau le plus sincère possible ça
pas l'air de tellement de pleurs de
faire un sacré coeur non ça ne plaît pas
ça ne plaît pas parce que c'est serré
c'est un tort de faire quelque chose qui
ressemble avec avec la motive
commerciales et nos pour ces voiliers
ferrari sacré coeur l'un porte à boire
et les autres qui y assistaient
d'ailleurs il est passé d'un recul du
non et si ça ne plaît pas pourquoi le
futur puisque il doit vivre
[Musique]
le sacré coeur ce gros choux à la crème
qui domine tout paris construit à la fin
du siècle dernier pour remercier le ciel
d'avoir épargné la ville pendant la
commune le sacré-coeur punition vous
ferez sans ville quand on n'est pas trop
là où faut faire de la couleur locale de
la carte postale montmartre des
clochards des poulbots ou de l'abstrait
riendeau de toiles non signés sur le
cheval et une sèche une en cours de ces
chiffres c'est le règlement or ce
règlement que la police fait appliquer
ni la mairie du 18e ni la préfecture
n'ont pu me dire qu'il a écrit
quel en est le texte exhorte ni même
s'il existe en famille il ya le père la
fille les enfants quand tu vois le père
la mère les enfants tout le monde tout
le monde travaille chez le poulbot y en
a trois qui restent à la maison
puis gamin qui vient les ventes face l
usine et alors tous les jours
alors là tous les jours c'est pas
marrant
tous les jours c'est vraiment pas drôle
parce que ça dépend il ya des bons
moments mais c'est pas drôle dans
général parce que tu es dans ton jeu
fallait bonté l'a d'abord tu bosses tu
bosses tu bosses pita des temps de
tartempion glissement à droite à gauche
qui viennent du moment éditeurs
commencent à satan merdé qui critiquent
à haute voix ou heures sont des
étrangers ne comprends pas ce qu'ils
disent mais tu es en tueur ils sont la
variable
j'étais gêné enfin quand tu travailles
tu aimes pas tellement difficile de
travailler dans la rue toujours un tas
de mecs ça lui tente un push it pose une
question
mais c'est combien leur truc
ou alors au macho au vif il trace cost
est enfin peu importe je comprends ils
disent n'importe quoi
se demande le prix dans leur langue où
ils disent n'importe quoi où tu
comprends que tu comprends pas
d'ailleurs tu sens qu'il ya ça accroche
s'appelait alors tu essaies tu expliquer
alors
tu as tu parles un petit peu avec les
mains tu dis bah c'est en ça coûte temps
c'est trop cher puissant que ça tic un
petit peu
c'est celui-là celui-là celui-là
quand et alors il faut être constant
faut être content quand tu as vendu un
russe est content tu as pris ton pognon
quand y'a pas un gars qui étaient là à
côté qu'il avait peur ni frais qu'ils
n'avaient pas le droit de toucher du
pognon en plein air police ça marche pas
bon oui les ventes sont illicites sur la
voie publique alors tu as beau expliquer
que sur le plan juridique c'est pas
considéré comme une vente que les
artistes sont protégés par l'état cpt
l'hébreu
tu parle l'hébreu comment fait il faut
se cacher ou alors tu invites tes
clients à les braques ou tu laisses ton
cheval est à garder un copain et puis tu
as au bistrot tu consommes fin
discrètement sur la table enfin tu as
plus l'air d'un voleur que d'un parfois
tu vois pratiquement il faut de cachet
pour faire ton boulot
quelque chose de la vie de peintre sur
la place est ce que c'est vraiment la
bohème comme au cinéma
j'ai bien convient c'est du cinéma
on nous présente pour toujours les
meilleures choses je crois que c'est
plus si on présentait de l'anecdote
bien sûr il ya de la bohème y en a plein
la bohème partout de tous les côtés
chouette de la bohème mais il ya aussi
le côté
j'arrive à telle heure je m'en vais à
telle heure un tu vois s'être un peu
tous les gens ont leur vie leur vie
privée alors il raconte des gosses si on
a quand une femme il y en a qu'on eut
organisé autour d'une structure comme le
foyer ou comme la communauté mais enfin
de toute façon il y a la bohème c'est
pas l'heure ah oui ça existe
on la connaît et on la vit et on la vie
oui et on la vit c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
fait quelquefois dire à mon épouse que
font la vie à pleins tubes même gagner
la province avait rappelé
vous accueillera et là de grandes
affiches avec 92,3 voilà allez plutôt
rigolo dit mais s'il a passé quatre
heures du matin elle s'est réveillée et
a gagné ses sous d'après des prêts et
une sorte avec les portland et s'ouvre à
moi je suis là toujours sans avoir gagné
un sou oui jusqu'où mais vous les coûts
quand on accepte et ont rejeté par tout
le monde ils sont un peu les aurès de la
place le portrait c'est le casse croûte
l'heure pas la chambre d'hôtel c'est un
visage que l'on massacre à grands coups
de fusain ou que l'on croque avec
passion la bagarre contre la ligne
la forme contre sa propre robe la quête
inlassable de grands cafards ou la
flamme la jouissance pirates du soleil
et de la main
[Musique]
et est-ce qu'on peut réellement vivre
vivre de ce que l'on fait sur la place
oui naturellement sinon il y aurait pas
autant de monde enfin en d'autres termes
est ce que ça rapporte
oui bien sûr apporte de quoi bouffer ça
rapporte de quoi même bouffer ou bien
pour certains ça rapporte que plus très
très bien la toile ça se fait à la
diable ça se travaille pleine pâte et ce
sont comme un petit pain chaud la
peinture n'est pas encore c'est scop
quelques taquet un bout de contreplaqué
s'est vendu entre 150 et 300 francs la
pièce parfois plus cher à raison de
quelques toiles par semaine on peut
vivre il faut tenir le coup
l'homme devant son chevalet finit par
n'être plus qu'une parade identique à
celle qui sort de ses tubes et qu'une
main gigantesque malaxe inlassablement
la foule les saisons la police des
autres quand l'homme est arrivé neuf
fois sur dix ils étaient en pleine
déroute paumé quelques années deux
places et le voilà debout aguerris et
désabusé est-ce que tu connais des gens
qui en sont sortis et bien sorti oui oui
et puis je crois même que c'est arrivé
un moment où ça suffit plus ou faut que
tu te surpasser il faut que tu ailles
quoi et il y en a qui en sont sortis
bien sorti même je dirais même qu'ils
n'en sont sortis qu'à partir du moment
où ils ont décidé de le faire tu vas
nombreux tubes c'est chacun qui voit ça
et pour moi j'ai c'est tout neuf mais
j'ai décidé c'est une décision j'en sors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]